hey everyone thanks for coming back to
Seeker Plus today I am trace this is
episode 2 of 3 in our new series on
internet obsession but really
information obsession in general I'll
explain why later make sure you
subscribe for more episodes and also you
can find an audio version of this story
and all of our other stories down below
in the description there's a link but
you can find us on Spotify iTunes
SoundCloud you name it we should be
there if we're not let us know you can
tweet at us at seeker or me
at-tracedominguez
okay enough of that today we're gonna
talk about how our obsession with
information is changing the world out
here I'm talking about the stuff that
you do on your phone and how it's gonna
be changing everything else that you do
when you're not on your phone we're
gonna talk about the history and
engineering and politics of information
obsession and so much more again make
sure you subscribe let's kick into it
okay so at the end of Act one
we were talking about getting obsessed
and how they get you obsessed they with
the quotes around it but does that
matter what could it possibly do and
what could that do to us is an
interesting question right but first we
have to understand how many people are
actually out there on the Internet
internet usage has exploded the
International Telecommunications Union
found in 2000 that there were seven
hundred and thirty eight million people
on the internet all over the world
that's not very many relative to the
world population of six billion or more
right that's it just seven hundred and
thirty eight million people in 2015 it
was 3.2 billion people that's like half
of every human that we know exists in
the universe and they're all on the
internet you know maybe there are other
humans somewhere else I'll have to wait
till Daniel figures out the Stargate to
do that but whatever on average
Americans spend ten hours a day staring
at their screens and that's at minimum
for me it's a lot more because you know
I'm staring at screens for you all what
we wanted to know is what all this
screen time is doing out in the world is
it really changing things not just in
the Estados Unidos you know we're
changing the infrastructure of countries
all over the planet in response to us
being obsessed with sucking information
out of the internet but let's be clear
this is not the first time this has
happened so before we get to the actual
infrastructure and the changes let's
address
history here because this is seeker plus
and we love it when we get to do some
history in the 1700s books finally
became affordable for the average person
you could just go out and buy a book and
this changed the world now we had
something called reading mania people
were really upset and scared because all
these people they weren't talking to
each other they weren't walking around
the town square I mean I don't actually
know that maybe they were but they were
reading books they had their heads down
reading a book remember the opening
lines of Beauty and the Beast this was a
real problem that people were worried
about it was derided and feared by the
1880s the New York Times wrote that
novels were unwholesome books were
unwholesome they were unwanted by the
media elite they wrote the novel reader
quote detests stories in which the
interest is not exaggerated and pulled
up ten times as high as the interests of
ordinary life they exaggerated normal
life in these books and ah who would
want that they called it unhealthy they
called reading spasmodic action of the
imagination it would affect our
imagination hmm that sounds so familiar
like perhaps our imaginations would be
affected by the media around us and we
would have shorter attention spans this
was in the 1880s today we have the
Journal of Neuroscience which did an
fMRI study where again they look at
blood flow to different parts of the
brain they also added something to that
to study what happens in our brains when
we read eye tracking so that way when
they were looking at the fMRI they knew
exactly which word people were looking
at while they were reading they called
this new system the fixation related
fMRI or fire MRI which just sounds
awesome their hypothesis was that when
you read you're associating real actions
in real life in your brain that's
represented in their research as well
the brain area is dealing with
manipulation of objects and carrying out
physical actions would light up when
people would read words on a page words
translate in our minds in our
imaginations to
real actions so if you're reading a
story about a wizard and you know living
in the UK or whatever you're picturing
those actual actions when he grasps his
wand you're picturing him in your head
grasping a wand another study done with
18th century literature specifically
found executive function also lit up and
our old friend the pleasure center
so not unlike social media today reading
helps give us reward in our brains we
like reading things we like social
interaction we like understanding we
like being entertained and we wanted
more of it so you know what we did we
learned to print and write and create a
whole supply chain to provide us with
that entertainment in this case in the
1880s it was with books we changed the
world around us to suit what we wanted
eventually we started creating other
things to do that same thing I'm gonna
fly through a few of them really quick
just to give you the idea I think you
probably get it but you know we're gonna
go Malcolm Gladwell and I'm gonna kick
the dead horse on this telephone's think
of all the pop culture there is around
telephones the sense of connection there
are not a lot of studies about this
telephone addiction kind of idea but I'm
sure we all know of people obsessing
over being connected about feeling
anxiety about missing our calls and we
can feel that and the New Scientist had
an op-ed in 1986 where they had
something that they dubbed the Tell
ahall ik which was a person who would
use the telephone for long periods they
could have 8 to 10 people on a single
call that was especially common with
teenagers and they were dubbed
antisocial and psychologically
imbalanced they were called sad bad mad
and shy sound familiar
of course it does you've probably heard
that about your social media use in
1980s as well New York Times writer
Trish Hall wrote the u.s. is becoming
addicted to telephone chatter some
people have as many as two telephones
for a single person can you believe it
there were also fax machines one guy was
called out which was a low mean for
faxing his girlfriend in Japan what are
we doing with ourselves they were asking
in the late 80s do young people have no
inhibitions seriously seriously they
were asking that people took this thing
that
and they started putting it around
telephones were everywhere we got them
at home we got them at work we got them
in airplanes in the 1980s and the media
kept commenting about how tella holics
were the reason we were doing this there
is some science behind this science
Reports has a study about social
interaction and how it gives people
meaning and it lights up in the ventral
striatum which you probably already have
guessed is part of the reward system our
good old friend what about television
addiction of course that exists as well
we've all heard and talked about that in
2003 a Scientific American piece wrote
about people who watch a lot of
television potentially having some kind
of substance dependence it was very
similar to drug uses what they were
trying to say you could have repeated
unsuccessful attempts to stop watching
TV and then you would get withdrawal
from the entertainment that you would
get while watching the Journal of
behavior addiction in 2013 did a
literature review of all of the
different studies around television
addiction and found the first mention of
it being back in 1954 televisions then
were much smaller black and white it's
very different time and they found that
it was addictions not unlike gambling
and substance abuse that most mirrored
television addiction and there were
behaviors that were involved as well
they called it food for the senses and
they said it was very shocking quote TV
addiction might be expected particularly
among persons experiencing inadequate
turnover of mezzo limbic dopamine that's
right
the reward system back again little
dance break so New York Times writer
Roland Neth away actually called
television quote an opiate for naive
children that was a headline we began to
change the infrastructure of the world
for all of these different things books
and telephones we crossed cables from
coast to coast we built dishes we
launched satellites we bounced the
signals off those satellites all to
satisfy this craving for information for
connection for social interaction right
and yes we haven't even gotten to the
internet yet this was all before that
dating back hundreds of years what I'm
trying to say by going through all of
these different things is we build the
infrastructure to serve what we want the
infrastructure doesn't just happen to us
and then we react
the world adapts to us we are not
victims of our infrastructure books gave
us unprecedented access to power
newspapers gave us unprecedented access
to power radio television cell phones do
remember the CrackBerry those of us who
are a little older yeah the CrackBerry
was what they called the blackberry
because people were just on it all the
time and now there's the internet we
adapt the real world to once over time
nearly 90% of American teens report
being active users on social media the
youth have continuously outpaced other
age groups in adopting new media that's
according to Leonard in 2015 and the
examples of how the infrastructure has
changed outside of you know building
cable lines and launching satellites to
communicate better and there are some
examples of how we've changed
infrastructure outside of launching
satellites and building cable lines and
such we physically changed roads and
sidewalks after the inventions of cell
phones for example in 2014 China added a
sidewalk lane in one of their cities DC
actually had one first here in the
United States as a joke but it was
copied around the world some people
actually thought maybe this is a good
idea to put people who are staring at
their cell phones in a separate lane in
the sidewalk as people who are you know
walking with purpose if you will I
couldn't actually find any follow-ups on
the original flurry of articles about
this in 2014 so if anybody knows if
those sidewalk lanes are still there if
they're used please tweet at us at
seeker there are people who are trying
to fight this around the world to make
sure that people aren't just looking at
their phones and walking around with
explicit infrastructure like in
Singapore where they're putting traffic
lights embedded in the sidewalk so you
know you're looking down at your phone
you can see the traffic light down there
and you know not to walk into into
traffic and hurt yourself they literally
have green and red signs embedded under
the sidewalk it's amazing there are
other places that do this as well the
Netherlands has crosswalks that are
built to keep you from using your phone
in Germany they have train stations that
are designed to make sure that people
using their phones don't get hurt and in
Thailand they also have mobile phone
lanes where people can walk and use
their phone at the same time it's pretty
amazing the Ohio State University has a
study where they talked about distracted
walking and they found that 1500
pedestrians were injured in 2010 alone
and that has doubled since 2005 and is
not just silly academics talking about
this the National Safety Council that
monitors all of this stuff found in 2017
there were 6,000 fatalities related to
people being on their phone and not
paying attention in Honolulu they're
actually making it illegal to look at
your phone while on a crosswalk you can
get a ticket for that and it's an
expensive one in the developed world
we're not changing the infrastructure
quite as much as in the developing world
mainly because we already have a lot of
it built but now that cell phones exist
the developing world is seeing a lot of
infrastructure change or maybe not
change that we would have had to do let
me give you an example
we built telegraph lines phone lines
cable lines and cell phone towers that
have cable and microwave connections to
each other in Nigeria everyone had a
cell phone but they probably didn't
build all of the infrastructure that we
built to get there they built mainly
cell phone towers right they didn't
necessarily need to build telephone and
telegraph lines to get information to
every single person's house everywhere
in the country the problem was they
didn't have internet access to Nigeria
the big back channel so that the
internet uses the big cables that are
underneath the water that ship it across
the world those didn't connect to
Nigeria so boom K o PK I don't actually
know if that's how to pronounce her name
but she is awesome she started a company
and got access to the Internet in
Nigeria through a backhaul service and
they got access to an undersea cable and
now people in Nigeria don't need cable
modems they can just use their cell
phones and access the Internet who needs
wires you know there are also all these
other plans to get Internet to places
without building all of this
infrastructure and you could argue that
these plans are infrastructure in
themselves balloons from Google
satellites from all sorts of different
companies drones from Facebook and a
whole bunch of other crazy ideas to try
and deliver Internet to people around
the world all in the feeding of this
information obsession over time we've
slowly demanded this stuff from
ourselves and there are people who are
legitimately addicted to their devices
to television to radio to
News but there are also millions more
who aren't addicted and are using these
services and with the internet just like
with telephones and letters and
newspapers they're pretty ubiquitous so
the point of this whole exercise is to
say a couple of things one information
obsession is not an internet thing it's
a human thing we've always had internet
obsession let's go back to reading mania
just for a second one quartz piece by
charles chu found when he did the math
that the amount of time we spend on
social media is equivalent to reading
about 200 books a year we could read
that in the same amount of time which is
pretty incredible but does that mean
things are worse now I mean if you had
reading mania couldn't you just read 200
books a year right
maybe it's the same maybe they were
reading 200 books a year and that was
freaking people out in the same way that
now we're reading our time lines all the
time and that's freaking people out
maybe they're the same I am not the
person to ask if it is you'd have to ask
scientists and researchers while
researching this piece there was a
really great piece on timeline comm it's
by luis anslo you can check the link in
the description it's really really cool
he did a lot of the research into
newspapers and headlines claims have
been made about addiction to various
technologies that we didn't get into
including comic books video games the
Internet of course and virtual reality
in a coming addictive way so this is
definitely a problem we're gonna keep
seeing but we've got the Internet now
it's it's on 3.2 billion people's phones
or computers right what happens when it
gets to everyone should we change how we
think about the internet and internet
obsession and information obsession
should we change that because in light
of what we learned earlier with people
taking advantage of our psychology and
our reward systems aren't we just giving
another 3 4 billion people up to this
problem shouldn't we fix it I don't know
how to do that maybe you have ideas you
can tell us in the comments do you even
think this is a problem you can tell us
that too maybe it's just something we
haven't gotten used to yet I don't think
there are people out there saying you
read too many books
right so maybe we just haven't gotten
used to this one yet we'll see what
comes next thanks everyone for watching
seeker + this week I'm trace you can
find me over on twitter at trace
Dominguez you can find us at seeker you
can find the third episode of this
series next week here on the YouTube
channel so make sure you subscribe you
can also find audio podcasts of all of
our stories over on Apple podcast
SoundCloud iTunes you name it were there
again thank you we'll see you next time